the version of Captain Marvel that hit
theaters was clipped down and polished
up missing a handful of scenes you'll
wish you got to see on a 50-foot screen
here's a look at all the scenes that
didn't make it to theaters while she's
still living on hala and going buy beers
Carole pays the supreme intelligence a
visit and sees it as Marvel aka dr.
Wendy Lawson the Kree scientists with
whom Carol worked in the US Air Force
young raagh accompanies her to the
meeting but the finished film doesn't
show him having his own encounter with
the AI overlord since the supreme
intelligence appears to its guest as the
person they most admire when young rogue
meets with it he naturally sees the
spitting image of himself the supreme
intelligence chastises young rogue for
the failures of his mission six years
prior from killing Marvel to not
retrieving the energy core she built and
leaving Carol alive as a supercharged
liability the usually cocky young rogue
is shaken and begs the supreme
intelligence to allow him to kill Carol
to make up worse mistakes a proposition
the AI denies bring us
alive
of all the films deleted scenes this is
the one that co-directors Anna Boden and
Ryan Fleck have said they wished made it
to theaters the most speaking to cinema
bland Boden said I think the scene where
Juve is 'it's his supreme intelligence
is really fun
Jude Law is playing both characters and
being both brutal and vulnerable in the
same space one deleted sequence features
young rogue lecturing a group of young
Star Wars hopefuls about the Kree
Empire's mission to protect itself from
the shape-shifting Scrolls
young rock teases the recruits about
potentially being shapeshifters
themselves before turning his attention
to beers calling her the best example of
Kree potential fears that enters the
room and shares her own disdain for the
scrolls the commanders write about the
scrolls they took everything from me my
home my family my memory she also calls
attention to the implant in her neck
which she still wholeheartedly believes
is a good thing and the source of her
powers our leader the supreme
intelligence saved me gave me purpose in
this implant it's like a fight back
early on in Captain Marvel the members
of Star Force flight at Orpha a planet
on the border of the Kree Empire to
locate and rescue the missing crease by
Salar the expedition ends up a total
failure when the scrolls successfully
snatch up beers as part of a trap before
things go south the movie was meant to
include some light-hearted banter
to send the Star Force gang off on a
happy note one deleted scene shows beers
joking around with Minerva Korath and
Atlas who tease are about a previous
mission to which she brought a little
too much heat with her photon blasting
fists that was not my fault we were
specifically told to bring the heat he
was very hot Minerva calling her by the
name of twinkle fists gives her a
sarcastic piece of advice think with
your head not with your hands the fun
momentarily stops when young raw arrives
and reminds them of the task at hand
bring Sol our home to hallow safely Ron
char manages to sneak in one last quip
as the Star Force team is loading into
their containment vessels
josepho grouping these things in an
extended version of Carol's interaction
with the man on the motorcycle things
get kicked up a notch after he asks her
for smile first of all we learned that
beers isn't the only character in the
scene with a weird name
I'm dears people call me the dawn
instead of a grin Carol asks if he's up
for a handshake he obliges but she uses
her fiery fists to burn his hand leaving
him helpless and her alien grip here's a
proposition for you
you're gonna give me your jacket your
helmet and your motorcycle and in return
I'm gonna let you keep your hands the
scene may have been cut for making our
heroine appear a little bit too much
like Marvel's own terminator which may
have been an intentional reference
considering the shared 90 setting as the
now in pain dawn hands Carol is keys she
places a sassy cherry on top of their
conversation ben mendelsohn gives a
chameleon ik performance as scroll
leader Talos while audiences still think
Talos is a villain he's shape shifts to
disguise himself as Keller the 90s era
director of shield what follows is a
cat-and-mouse game between Talos Carroll
and Nick Fury one scene that got sniped
from this plot shows Keller attempting
to track down the quad jet Carol and
Nick stole from the Air Force Academy
you're telling me you can't track your
all play since the plane has anti radar
tech there's no way for Talos to
immediately locate it which means he's
further away from discovering the truth
about Carol wendy lawson and the
location of his family but when another
SHIELD agent hands taillow some intel on
the crash sites of maria lambo his
chances of cracking the whole thing wide
open greatly improved
speaking of tailo so another Captain
Marvel scene you didn't get to see
reveals what happened to the real shield
director after the green skin scroll
stole his look it would have played out
right after Talos as Keller said goodbye
to his fallen skull comrade the one who
Nick Fury killed while he was
impersonating Phil Coulson things and
they're in the theatrical cuts but the
deleted scene keeps going making sure
it's clear to everybody that there's
some shape-shifting going on out of the
hallway the true Agent Coulson passes by
Nick Fury and offers to be his partner
in the ongoing investigation Fury
rejects him
here's the police report you asked for
need a partner and now Luke trying to
prove himself useful Colson jumps at the
chance to help Keller get into his
office not knowing it's actually Talos
who forgot to grab Keller's ID card when
he first took his form who's the rookie
now Colson happily swipes his keycard
through the scanner on the wall granting
talos access to the real Keller's office
there we see the shield director on the
floor bound and unconscious and watches
tail oh scraps Keller's badge from
underneath his jackets but like some of
the other sequences it makes sense why
this scene was cut the only people it
would play as a reveal too would be
viewers just getting back from the
bathroom check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]